they are asking for for freedom you know
libertad
freedom freedom freedom
alongside thousands of other cubans
katyuska's brother marched in protest
two weeks on from the largest
anti-government demonstrations in
decades
and this video is the last family and
friends have seen of enrique mustelia
souza
katiewska believes based on what
eyewitnesses have told her
that like others enrique too was
arrested and beaten by plainclothes
police officers
children aged 11 and 15 are still in
cuba
it was a choice she says between keeping
the family together
or feeding them it's very sad
it's very sad for us we need freedom we
need
help like many cuban exiles katyuska has
made miami her home
from little havana they've watched other
ill-fated attempts to overthrow the
communist ruling party
but this uprising they say feels
different
it was documented and broadcast by the
protesters themselves online
ramon has devoted his life to fighting
the cuban government
from miami this is why the regime
immediately goes and turns off the
internet when there is a revolt
what they're doing right now is slowing
it down
if we had had social media 20 years ago
what we're seeing now probably would
have happened then
protesters may have more profile but
activists say they're being punished in
summary trials without defense lawyers
the cuban government however say they
are receiving counsel
and there's nothing unfair or
extraordinary about it there's a lot of
hope
you know but there's also a lot of fear
the government repression has been
brutal
more brutal than ever before and we do
know that there's over 500 people that
are currently missing
that number is not accurate because
there's so many more that we haven't
been able to hear from
the people may not take to the streets
in cuba again today or tomorrow
but there is a belief here that
eventually they will
a protest movement led by young people
who want they say
to thrive not just survive martha
kellner
sky news miami